we hear it so much that it feels like a
buzzword but it is far from it climate
change is a real and serious issue but
isn't the climate always changing
what exactly is climate change why
should we care
well the Earth's climate has changed
throughout history most of these slight
changes are caused by small variations
in the Earth's orbit but climate change
as we know it today is characterized by
an abrupt increase in the earth's
temperature it is estimated to have
gotten 1.2 to 1.4 degrees Fahrenheit
warmer in just the last century 10 out
of the last 13 years were the warmest on
record 97% of climate scientists agree
that this new tendency is not caused by
the variations of the Earth's orbit but
rather very likely caused by human
activities that means you mean and since
the Industrial Revolution we have come a
long way humans built airplanes faster
cars developed remarkable technology and
learned how the natural resources around
us can be used for our benefit although
this has led to many wonderful
inventions and advancements like the
device you're using to watch this video
or the ability to take a plane halfway
around the world
it also means we've increased our
consumption of natural resources and in
turn released a lot of greenhouse gases
into the atmosphere
now greenhouse gases occurred naturally
but in excess can be dangerous to our
planet modern human activities have
increased the release of non naturally
occurring greenhouse gases because we
have stepped up our demand for burning
fossil fuels the composition of
greenhouse gases traps heat radiated
from the Sun the more heat they trap the
warm our planet gets and as our planet
gets warmer we begin to feel the effects
what if climate changes biggest victims
our oceans oceans regularly through
earth's temperature and provide 50
percent of the Earth's oxygen a climate
change has increased the global
temperature of the oceans by more than
0.3 degrees Fahrenheit since 1969
although a warmer ocean might seem
inviting to a beach goer it actually has
devastating consequences for supporting
life at sea one of those consequences is
ocean acidification a direct effect of
increased dissolved co2 since the late
18th century ocean surface acidification
is increased by 30% a higher acid
content means calcifying species
like oysters and clams and shell water
corals are at risk putting the entire
ocean food web at risk this is bad news
for the one building people relying on
the ocean as its primary source of
protein climate changes also caused the
sea level to rise just in the last
century sea levels have risen six point
seven inches but the rate in the last
decade is nearly doubled sea levels have
risen because as the ocean gets warmer
it swells on top of that glaciers and
ice sheets are melting an article 36
cubic miles of ice between 2002 and 2005
and since 1994 each year on average the
earth has lost 400 billion tons from its
glaciers that's like an ice cube seven
and a half kilometres on a site for
miles on a side melting and flowing into
the sea when all that ice melts it fills
up our oceans and just like filling up a
bathtub the shores can't hold all that
water and coastal regions get flooded
troubling signs of climate change are
increased extreme weather events natural
disasters like floods tornadoes and
deadly heat waves are more obvious to
humans because of their immediate impact
and their sharing of the images in the
media climate change as we know it today
is change in our Earth's overall
temperature with massive and permanent
ramifications although its consequences
can be planet threatening scientists
still believe there are things we can do
on a personal level to help recycle and
reuse things walk or use public
transportation to get to work turn off
your electronics when you're not using
them eat less meat while you're at it
eat more locally grown vegetables and
foods and last but not least spread your
knowledge and concerns about climate
change with others when it comes to
climate change the main takeaway is that
it's real and although we are part of
the cause we can also be part of the
solution